sources tell CBS News more Americans are
reporting mysterious illnesses and
deaths in the Dominican Republic a New
Jersey man is the at least the eighth
person to die while on vacation in the
Caribbean nation during the past year
that his cause of death has not been
released some tour groups are also
reporting multiple incidents of
travelers getting sick mola Lanie is
there this morning Joseph Allen's family
says he traveled to the Dominican
Republic frequently and was in good
health
they say the 55 year old was staying at
Terre Linda resort in Sosua last week
with friends who say he was complaining
about being hot at the pool he went to
take a shower and lie down for the night
then was found dead the next day at
least seven other Americans have died in
the Dominican Republic in the last 12
months
local autopsies concluded most died of
respiratory problems or a heart attack
some seemingly quite healthy people seem
to be having heart attacks out of the
blue mark Hurlbut jr. says his father
died from heart and respiratory problems
last June in Punta Cana I had I known
then what I know now I would have fought
tooth and nail to have his remains
brought back here and have an American
autopsy done tourist groups are also
reporting concerns five members of an
Oklahoma high school group staying at
the Hard Rock Hotel and Casino became
violently ill after eating at a Japanese
restaurant and more than 50 Jimmy
Buffett fans were sickened while on an
annual trip in April at least one tested
positive for Salmonella last week
Josef's Allen's family is still trying
to get his body back to the United
States meanwhile we are still waiting on
FBI toxicology reports on the three
deaths that occurred here on the island
back in May the US embassy here in Santo
Domingo that tells us that at this point
there is no link between any of these
deaths also health officials say that
heart attacks are the most common cause
of death for Americans on vacation
Anthony mola legi with a continuing
mystery and the Dominican Republic
thanks